WHAT MESSAGE DOES IT SEND FOR
THE UNITED STATES TO PRESS
ALLIES TO PROVIDE TANKS TO
UKRAINE WHEN IT WON'T DO THE
SAME?
>> AN UNHELPFUL MESSAGE I THINK
AT THIS POINT, WOLF.
LOOK, THERE ARE UNDERSTANDABLE
REASONS FOR NOT WANTING TO GIVE
THE M1 ABRAMS TANK, THE U.S.
MAIN BATTLE TANK.
IT'S MUCH HEFBIAN THAN THE
OTHERS.
IT'S A GOOD TEN TIMES HEAVIER
THAN THE GERMAN TANK.
IT'S MUCH MORE DIFFICULT TO
MAINTAIN.
IT'S A JET ENGINE BASICALLY A
TURBINE SURROUNDED BY ARMOR.
THE SPARE PARTS AND ALL THE REST
OF THAT, THE DIAGNOSTICS ARE
VERY, VERY CHALLENGING.
THAT SAID IF GIVING 14 TANKS,
SAY ARMORED COMPANY'S WORTH OF
TANKS TO UKRAINE ALLOWS THE
GERMANS TO PROVIDE THEIR TANKS
AND TO APPROVE THAT OTHER
COUNTRIES HAVE POLAND, BALTIC
STATES, FINLAND AND OTHER STATES
OF NATO THAT HAVE THOSE, I THINK
IT'S VERY MUCH WORTH IT.
AND I THINK IT'S TIME TO GET ON
WITH THIS, FRANKLY.
THIS IS ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE
PIVOTAL MOMENTS IN UKRAINE.
THE BATTLE LINES HAVE BEEN
PRETTY STATIC.
RUSSIA HAS BEEN MAKING
INCREMENTAL GAINS AT GREAT COST,
BUT THEY'RE ON THE OFFENSIVE.
WE KNOW THAT UKRAINE HAS SAID
THAT THEY'RE PLANNING AN
OFFENSIVE FOR THE SPRING.
IF THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
COMPETENT AND CAPABLE COMBINED
ARM CAPABILITIES NOT JUST TANKS
BUT ARTILLERY, MOTORS, AIR
DEFENSE, ENGINEERS, ET CETERA,
YOU'VE GOT TO TRAIN FOR THAT.
SOME OF THAT IS ONGOING RIGHT
NOW IN OUR TRAINING BASE IN
GERMANY.
TOMORROW IS A HUGELY IMPORTANT
GATHERING OF THE COALITION THAT
COMES TOGETHER OF NATO AND
WESTERN COUNTRIES TO PROVIDE
ARMS AMMUNITION AND ASSISTANCE
TO UKRAINE.
I THINK IT WOULD SEND A VERY
IMPORTANT MESSAGE FOR US TO SAY,
LOOK, IF GIVING, AGAIN, 14 TANKS
OF OURS TO FREE UP THE LEAH PART
2s AND OTHER COUNTRIES WANT TO
GIVE, AND POLAND IS EAGER TO DO
THAT, AND MANY OF THOSE WILL BE
REPLACED BY THE M1 ABRAMS TANK,
ULTIMATELY, LET'S GET ON WITH
IT.
IN ADDITION TO WHAT ARE GOING TO
BE OTHER IMPORTANT ANNOUNCEMENT
BY THE U.S., WHICH OF COURSE HAS
DONE AN INCREDIBLE JOB OF
LEADING THE WORLD IN PROVIDING
STAGGERING QUANTITIES OF ARMS,
AMMUNITION AND MATERIAL.
OVER $24 BILLION JUST SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE INVASION.
AND THIS SEEMS TO ME TO BE A
PRETTY MODEST INCREMENT IN THAT,
YES, IT'S A STRATEGIC DECISION,
BUT WE SHOULD GET ON WITH THIS.
>> I KNOW YOU SAID THAT, GENERAL
PETRAEUS, THAT PUTIN STILL
CLEARLY BELIEVES RUSSIA CAN WIN
THIS WAR.
WHAT WILL IT TAKE TO CONVINCE
PUTIN THAT'S NOT POSSIBLE?
>> WELL, IT'S GOING TO TAKE A
COMPREHENSIVE EFFORT, WOLF.
OBVIOUSLY ON THE BATTLEFIELD
WHERE HE'S ALREADY LOST PROBABLY
NINE TIMES MORE SOLDIERS IN 11
MONTHS THAN THE USSR LOST IN
NEARLY TEN YEARS IN AFGHANISTAN,
THAT HAS TO CONTINUE,
TRAGICALLY, TERRIBLY.
BUT ALSO THERE HAVE TO BE
FURTHER EFFORTS TO TIGHTEN THE
FINANCIAL, ECONOMIC, AND
PERSONAL SANCTIONS AND ALSO THE
EXPORT CONTROLS SO WHAT PUTIN IS
TRYING TO DO, TWO DAYS AGO HE
ANNOUNCED HIS PLANS TO INCREASE
THE SIZE OF THE RUSSIAN MILITARY
BY 150 OR 200,000 SOLDIERS.
THERE'S ANOTHER CONSCRIPTION
DRIVE EXPECTED, AND HE'S TRYING
TO REVIVE THE MILITARY
INDUSTRIES IN RUSSIA TO PROVIDE
THE ARMS AND AMMUNITION FOR THIS
EXPANDED FORCE AS WELL.
AGAIN, HE'S GOT TO BE CONVINCED
THAT THIS IS UNSUSTAINABLE ON
BOTH THE BATTLEFIELD AND ON THE
HOME FRONT, AND THAT TAKES A LOT
OF ACTIVITY, COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH TO DO THAT.
BUT ABOVE ALL THERE HAS TO BE
UNWAVERING DETERMINATION ON THE
PART NOT JUST OF THE COURAGEOUS
UKRAINIANS WHO HAVE DEMONSTRATED
THAT IN STATES BUT ALSO AMONG
THE EUROPEANS AND AMERICANS.
>> RETIRED GENERAL DAVID
PETRAEUS, THANKS AS USUAL FOR
JOINING US.
WE APPRECIATE IT VERY, VERY
MUCH.